I feels amazing being Wimbledon champion
but what sunk in in particularly was the
occasion of yesterday I think you know
being on center court was Andy Murray
first Briton so long to to make the
Wimbledon finals and just being part of
that incredible moment I think that's
what now hits me the most that I was
able to handle you know the situation
well and actually Andy - I have to
praise him as well because I think we
played a great match at a very high
level under difficult circumstances
because there was a lot on the line for
him for me too
outdoors first finished indoors I mean
it's it's it's nerve-wracking and and
tough so we'd always it was always gonna
finish in tears for someone in some way
so it was emotional it was nice to see
and anyway that's kind of what how I
feel right now you know a few hours
later it was a good final Ferranti but
not quite good enough what do you think
he needs to do to win one of these
really big matches against you or anyone
I think I think he's improving and I
think that's what's most important right
now for him and then not stop believing
and then take these experiences and take
the positives out of them and not to
have a letdown the way he didn't have a
sort of a letdown in 2010 a little bit
after he lost against me in in Australia
after that he had a bit of a he was a
bit down it seemed like and he had some
shock early losses and some tournaments
I mean that can happen it's no problem
but it's the mindset that counts for him
now and I think what's gonna help him is
actually that the Olympics are gonna be
back here so he has right away a chance
to sort of forget about the loss and
move on and recreate something
extraordinary here in Berlin but for the
Olympic Games this time and you know for
the country so it's a it's it's a big
it's a big moment in his in his career
and I think he's only going up from here
and not down which is
good thing for them